الاحتجاجات هو في كل انحاء البلاد ولهذا
فارقم المعتقلين كبيره الانتفاضه ارض
اربكت النظام سباق تعكسه اوراق مبعثره غير
منظمه تبدو في حاله فوضى امام مكبر
التحقيق الاممي تماما كما تعاني السلطات
وبين ما تستمر والاحتجاجات
موحده وثابته السلطات تحاول الابتكار لكن
ليس من اجل الحل وانما للقمع سيارات
الاسعاف احدى الوسائل تستغلها للتسلل
للتظاهرات من اجل نقل المصابين ثم يحدث ما
تريده الاعتقال الاعداد تتزايل تحقيق
النيويورك تايمز احد الشهود العيان قال
انه راى ما لا يقل عن ثلاثه متظاهرين ايه
الزاج بهم في سياره اسعاف خلال مظاهره
طلابيه لكن المتظاهرين لم يكونوا مصابين
من الاساس شاهد اخر الصحيفه التايمز
البريطانيه حللت وحددت المواقع الجغرافيه
لمقاطع الفيديو السيارات الاسعاف هذه تدخل
وتخرج من مراكز الشرطه او يتم وضعها
خارجها مباشره وربما تفيد هذه المعلومات
جهه التحقق الامميه
[موسيقى]